oh hi we just finished up watching
sony's press conference here at e3 2009
Chris Baker what did you like the most
there were a lot of great games
uncharted two among thieves look at a
very impressive demo god of war 3 had a
very impressive demo and I really like
the demonstration of the new I toy
peripheral up you know as for me it's
got to be it wasn't really a demo it was
a video but the Last Guardian it is the
third game in the trilogy from Team eco
for member eco or shadow of the colossus
another absolutely amazing looking game
from these guys check out some of this
video just just watch it just enjoy it
well it's just about playstation 3 sony
also has the PSP and they just announced
the PSP go it has no UMD drive it is
going to download games only it is going
to come out on october first for two
hundred and fifty dollars this is Baker
what do you think two hundred fifty
dollars going to pay that well I've
already got one I I do think it's smart
that those little UMD discs weren't
doing them any favors it's an
interesting gamble Baker did you say do
you say you already have a PSP go I
already have a PSP wow I say but what
don't you know I mean that that's worth
keeping in mind this is not a new
handheld device this is just a new
iteration of the PSP you'll still be
able to get a lot of the same games
they'll still continue to make games
that run on UMD desks yeah Sony was very
clear you know this the the PSP that you
have is going to have all the
functionality of this machine it's just
if you want that smaller form factor
that sliding screen and no moving parts
no Drive sony also said in conjunction
with this from now on every PSP game is
going to be available on disk and also
via download I mean that is just bowing
to reality and I think a lot of people
are downloading games for their PSP
right now they're just not paying for
them so this is a way to meet that
piracy head on hopefully the pricing is
right are there some sort of
subscription model but I think Sony had
to do this yeah we'll see they really
were very short on details in terms of
how that's going to work but they were
big on PSP titles we've got Resident
Evil portable coming from Capcom and
Hideo Kojima's showed off the first
trailer from metal gear solid peace
walker a PSP exclusive metal gear solid
game which think about peace walker
that's kind of like moonwalker something
is that a dance move but i think it is
this sort of dance movie deal when
you're a giant giant robot sony also had
two pretty huge announcements number one
very much like Microsoft they are doing
a motion controller it's going to use a
camera in conjunction with a wiimote
style wand controller it moves exactly
as he moves this is true one to one
tracking
but then it's going to actually you know
put stuff on screen that appears in
place to the controller so maybe the
controller becomes a baseball bat you
can see yourself swinging it maybe it's
a tennis racquet maybe it's a sword what
do you think about that yeah you and I
have both seen Microsoft solution in
action which is just a camera that reads
your body and you're just moving your
body to control it I saw more immediate
gameplay potential in what Sony's
offering you know just to thing in your
hand that could be anything it's
completely modular it's whatever
developers come up with I like the
tactile nature of that and I see more
immediate gameplay possibilities
Microsoft's we both seen it in action it
definitely works yeah it'll be
interesting to see what developers do
with it but Sony had some really nice
demos like let's look at some of some of
the stuff is showing off you know that
the sword fighting and the bow and arrow
I like the the first person shooter
where you can actually move around in
the room in space and it and it tracks
that attracts your motion I mean it's
all it is all very interesting stuff
Sony said that it's going to be
available in spring 2010 and finally
after Microsoft made a big deal of
announcing the final fantasy 13 is going
to come to Xbox as well as playstation
sony just announced today that final
fantasy 14 will be exclusive to
playstation 3 and it also like final
fantasy 13 is coming next year in 2010
that's right to Final Fantasy games on
the PlayStation 3 in 2010 how is that
possible well Final Fantasy 14 is a
massively multiplayer online game it's
not a single player RPG like the rest of
the final fantasy series it's another
game in the vein of final fantasy 11
it's an MMO which was a very very
popular MMO I think before World of
Warcraft came along and Reese everyone's
expectations the final fantasy MMO was
one of the most popular things going and
this really had a nice looking graphics
for an mmm and also should be big ya
know it should be really interesting to
see what happens with final fantasy 13
and 14 in the same year
you